hey guys welcome back to brand-new video
we're back on apex legends again and
today it's gonna be a really quick video
nothing too crazy no info nothing like
that but more of a quick PSA because I
just want to let everybody know that
there's ads flowing about all the way
through YouTube and probably some other
places as well talking about a mobile
apex legends game now a lot of people
are probably aware of all this stuff
that happened in fortnightly happened
and Call of Duty and it's no secret
obviously there is no mobile game for
apex legends so most people are just
gonna dislike it as shown at there's
that ton of dislikes on the video but
there are those few impressionable kids
or other people that don't are unaware
of this and mike gets caught up in this
scheme so i just wanted to let you guys
know do not buy this when you go to the
description of the video it actually
send you to a link in that link will
probably most likely give you a virus on
your computer or your phone or whatever
it happens to be so don't even bother
with it I've done with viruses in the
past on my computers and my setup and
it's a pain in the ass to get rid of
them I had a call some guy to help me
out and that was four years ago and I
was really stupid I mean I'm still
stupid now but I'm not stupid enough to
go download a virus from some scammy ass
looking place if he needed a little bit
more confirmation on if this was
actually true or not first off apex
elated is not even on mobile yet the
devs have even stated that it's not on
mobile and on top of that if you look at
the gameplay throughout the game on the
phone first off it's cropped into the
phone and second of all it actually
shows PC key bindings I believe it's
like effigy is shown by the grenades or
something so obviously there is no you
can't use the keyboard while playing on
a phone so it's obviously PC gameplay
and it's taken from some guys stream as
there's a subscriber alert that comes up
so someone took this from some dudes
stream playing PC and slapped it into an
ad and as well since I might as well be
talking about this as well if you see
any ads or something on YouTube or
anything like that talking about free
apex coins don't also get those either
this has also been the same for cod
points in black ops 4 and V bucks for
fortnight there is no way that you can
get actual V box or actual apex coins
using some type of generator or hack it
is all completely fake and you will get
tons of viruses on your computer
basically [ __ ] up your entire thing
and while it seemed like it's truthful
but really the only way to do that is by
supporting the company and buying it
with own real cash hey guys gonna be
into the video I just wanted to do a
quick PSA for anybody else unaware of
this type of ad going around YouTube
obviously like I said this is fake and
if anyone else sees this or is thinking
about it just send them this video or
just tell them that it's completely fake
it's pretty obvious they did a poor job
at trying to portray that this was real
so just be aware of those in try not to
do those in the future I mean I trust
most of you guys probably watching this
video already have seen these and it's
like alright these are clearly fake
we're just gonna get rid of them and
just not talk about it because it's a
it's obvious that these are fake but
there are a few people that may run into
this and think that this is possible
we'd like to be if you do enjoy
subscribe if you're new I cover the
informational side of apex legends so if
you never want to miss in a single
update within the world of apex let's
definitely subscribe to the channel and
that guy's my two most recent videos
will be on the screen if you guys want
to check that out other guys so ever
greatest today thank for watching the
video do not touch this scam and peace
out
[Music]
you
[Music]